trois ans après le début de son mandat
emmanuel macron fait le point sur sa
politique sécuritaire
lors d'un entretien accordé au quotidien
le figaro le chef de l'état dit se
battre pour le droit à la vie paisible
avant d'évoquer des promesses faites
pendant sa campagne
parmi elles l'objectif de créer dix
mille postes de policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires d'ici la fin de son
quinquennat
on tiendra le calendrier et il est
normal qu'on parvienne à l'objectif
progressivement puisqu'il faut le temps
de former les policiers recrutés ils
seront tous sur le terrain avant la fin
du quinquennat
aujourd'hui 4508 policiers et 1706
gendarmes ont déjà été recrutés soit
6214 membres des forces de l'ordre
nous aurons un complément des sept
années 2000 policiers et gendarmes de
plus
et parmi ces nouveaux policiers
l'essentiel iront directement sécurité
publique c'est à dire sur la voie
publique
parmi ces renforts qui devraient arriver
lors des prochains mois on décompte 135
nouveaux postes à lyon 100 à marseille
ou encore 117 à lille outre ces renforts
sur le terrain
emmanuel macron a dévoilé qu'une réserve
nationale de 30000 hommes sera créé dans
la police
celle de la gendarmerie passera quant à
elle de 38 à 50 me l'homme selon le
président français
emmanuel macron souhaite rassurer les
français en mettant plus de forces de
l'ordre dans les rues des mots qui ne
passe pas dans l'opposition
certains membres de la droite notamment
de la droite nationaliste n'ont pas
hésité à critiquer les déclarations du
président français
cet hymne gay revue de macron ne
rassemble que des slogans électoraux à
un an de la présidentielle alors que
depuis quatre ans les actes défaillant
conduit à l'explosion de la délinquance
à des niveaux d'immigration record et à
une montée inédite de l'islamisme le
président du chaos de la violence
partout tout le temps de la division de
l'injustice sociale fiscale territoriale
nous vend aujourd'hui la vie paisible
rien ne nous sera épargné
quand vous êtes président de la
république vous n'annoncez pas vous fait
il est président depuis 2017
les effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie ils sont dix mille policiers
ce n'est rien j'en ai demandé trente
mille il faut un référendum sur une
procédure pénale renouvelé et pas de
bracelet électronique
mais des peines appliquées en prison
il n'y a pas un pays au monde plus
laxiste avec les délinquants dans son
entretien au figaro emmanuel macron a
révélé qu'il souhaitait lancer un grand
débat national sur la consommation de
drogue et ses effets le président
français a également réaffirmé qu'il
tiendrait sa promesse de créer quinze
mille places supplémentaires dans les
prisons d'ici 2027
si 7000 d'entre elles ont été lancées en
il n'est pas certain qu'elles seront
prêtes comme promis en 2022
le quotidien le monde révélait en
juillet 2019 qu'en raison d'une baisse
du budget de la justice
la création des structures
d'accompagnement à la sortie allait être
repoussé
il en va de même pour deux prisons
expérimental qui selon le quotidien
devrait attendre un minima 2023 pour
voir le jour